if we want to have a conversation about
things that should not be for profit
health care is obviously on this list
and we've been talking about that for
years and that seems to often be the one
that is the most obvious to the largest
number of people although there's still
some debate about that in some political
circles we could talk about whether
education should be for profit we could
talk about whether student lending
should be for profit or certain types of
housing or whatever else but
increasingly we should be talking about
the internet which at this point is
really just a utility which underlies
almost everything we do at this point
and I'm gonna probably end up repeating
this again but to be a full participant
in 2019 society and economy you
effectively need access to the Internet
and probably high-speed Internet at that
and there are individual towns that have
done what's called municipal broadband
but the reason that they've done this is
that usually those towns are too small
for the big Internet service providers
to want to come in and set up shop and
be the monopoly provider in those
municipalities and so I was thrilled to
see that 2020 Democratic presidential
candidate and Massachusetts senator
Elizabeth Warren put out her plan
yesterday for an Internet
public option along with her plan by the
way to bring back net neutrality and as
we've talked about with medicare-for-all
a public option is better than nothing
it may not be the ideal and with
Internet it's probably similar but I
still want to deal with this in detail
today because it could be a really big
improvement over what we have and here
is Elizabeth Warren's idea you pass a
federal law to prevent States from
restricting towns that want to do public
broadband that's number one number two
you do a federal grant for 85 billion
dollars which will be set up to cover
90% of the costs for utility co-ops
nonprofits cities and counties that want
to lay fiber for their own broadband
networks the federal government will
subsidize ninety percent of it so the
city town co-op whatever only has to pay
for 10 percent of it for-profit entities
would not be eligible for that grant
which will push a lot of Internet
service over to nonprofits and co-ops
and municipalities which would be great
to qualify for the money the
organization that is looking to do this
is going to have to agree to provide at
least one affordable plan for low-income
people a special low price
to increase access to Internet
particularly for low-income people and
meanwhile yeah Elizabeth Warren would
also restore net neutrality she would
appoint commissioners which would
regulate the internet as a common
carrier that's a huge huge thing so the
breaking news here which is not breaking
news to lots of people in my audience is
that both sides aren't the same on many
issues when they are I tell you I've
been crystal clear that too many issues
have Republicans and Democrats basically
working together to maintain the status
quo and to reinforce that status quo
when Democrats require criticism I'm
there criticizing them but on lots of
important issues the two parties are not
the same one issue we've talked about
already and could it ever be more clear
than now under Donald Trump rather than
Hillary Clinton
choosing judges in the United States
Supreme Court justices and lower-level
judges as we talked about on the bonus
show this week Donald Trump's power to
do that has had such a significant
impact that will be long lasting Donald
Trump's judicial choices more sort of
celebrated in the Supreme Court but also
in lower-level courts as we've talked
about will have an effect on the
judiciary of the United States for
decades to come
Hillary Clinton would have been very
different on that you might not like her
position on whatever but Democrats and
Republicans drastically different on
that it's very similar with the internet
regulation and net neutrality
in 2018 all Democrats and three
Republicans voted to restore net
neutrality okay in the house a few
months ago 231 Democrats and one
Republican in the House voted to restore
net neutrality and then Mitch McConnell
Republican Senate Majority Leader
blocked it from even coming up in the
Senate at all so we need to support
candidates with the right views on this
issue
I love that Elizabeth Warren I've made
no secret I think it's great that she's
been running one of the most substantive
campaigns of 2020 so far slowly but
surely creeping up in the polls and she
did it again in a couple of recent polls
which I don't have time to talk about
today but maybe we'll deal with on
Monday she has been doing that with
substantive policy proposals no cheap
shots no you know debate kill shot
attempts the way some other candidates
have been doing just policy detailed
policy which she's increasingly good at
explaining in clear and direct terms and
that's a really good thing so bottom
line in 2019 you essentially need
Internet and and I would argue not just
internet but high-speed Internet to
fully participate in society and in the
economy period flat-out thus it should
be a public utility anything short of
that falls short of the goal but these
public option programs like what
Elizabeth Warren is suggesting here are
absolutely great ideas I think that
legally they are quite simple so when
Elizabeth Warren talks about oh I want
to pass a wealth tax okay you could like
the idea and not like the idea I think
it's the right way or the wrong way to
reduce inequality think that inequality
isn't an issue but legally it will be
very complex to get a wealth tax pass
that's just the reality this public
option internet plan and the
reinstatement of net neutrality would
not be legally complicated it could be
complicated in the terms of lobbyists in
terms of lobbyists opposition and
massive ad dollars lobbying just average
people to be against it and massive
lobbying dollars lobbying politicians to
be against that that will be complicated
but when it comes to the legality of
doing it there are not constitutional
issues there are not commerce issues or
any other issues that I'm aware of it's
merely the political will and that's why
this is absolutely fantastic let me know
what you think about these and other net
neutrality and internet utility ideas
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show is
on twitter at david pakman show and the
david pakman show is now on twitch at
twitch.tv slash david pakman hope you'll
follow us there and subscribe with
twitch prime if you have an Amazon
I'm account do you stand for women's
rights and for the environment there's a
phone company that also does and that's
credo mobile credo is the only phone
company in the u.s. supporting the same
causes you do causes like fighting
climate change
protecting reproductive freedom
immigrants rights every month
credo donates a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars to groups like Planned
Parenthood and the ACLU and the
Rainforest Action Network and others
meanwhile other phone companies are
spending millions of dollars pushing
mega-mergers through and funding
right-wing politicians you're making
choices every time you spend a dollar
your mobile phone is one of those
choices and you can switch to credo
mobile now as a reward you will get
twelve pints of Ben and Jerry's ice
cream a pint a month for 12 months and
you'll get coverage on the nation's
largest most reliable network with low
rates and a full selection of smart
phones including the latest models from
the top brands make the switch today go
to credo mobile.com slash Pakman mm-hmm
or enter the offer code Pakman at
checkout
that's CRE do.com slash Pakman